get ready for Riverdale episode unlike
any other so let's blast into the past
on Sweetwater secrets hello River babes
welcome to the after show for episode
304 chapter 39 the midnight club
I'm your host leonid gill era and for
the first time on Sweetwater I'm
channeling my inner Alice Cooper in
honor of this week's epic flashback
episode what do you think I mean
technically I'm Alice Smith right now
but I love all Alice dude can you bite
me now today I'll be bringing you scoop
from both Alice's Lily Reinhart and
machen
Amick as well as onset secrets from Mark
Consuelos and his son Michael who played
young Hyrum we also have so many
relationship revelations and hisses and
kisses to hash out but first let's recap
all the flashback festivities in the
blue and gold breakdown now as Betty
continued to try and piece together the
g and g pieces she confronted her mom
with an old file about another
blue-lipped murder
Alice agreed to finally take time away
from her farm shenanigans and tell Betty
a story from her senior year at
Riverdale high and from there we were
introduced to young versions of Alice F
P Fred Hermione Sierra and Penelope I
thought I heard a party in here these
strangers all ended up in a series of
Saturday detentions together and after
discovering a game called
Griffin's and gargoyles they became
closer and more and more addicted to the
game after deciding to kick things up a
notch the group known as The Midnight
Club had ascension Knight and everyone
except newly pregnant Alice takes a drug
called fizzle rocks and roams around the
school in a crazed haze
now when Alice found herself sick in the
bathroom that night she emerged from the
stall to see the bathroom covered in
creeper writing and there were two
mysterious chalasis and I had no idea
what was going on but I was intrigued
upon seeing her first glimpse at the
gargoyle King and realizing the
principle feather head was about to bust
everyone
Alice noped out of the ascention night
party but it turns out the principal was
murdered that night and no one knows how
or why midnight club decided to never
tell anyone what had really happened and
the group of friends went their separate
ways
meanwhile back in present-day Riverdale
Betty went to tell Jughead her mother's
whole story but discovered that her
serpent king and the rest of her
slithering friends were now deeply
addicted to G and G I'm a level-3 and
it's only a matter of time until I
ascended okay and if you're like me you
probably wanted a lot more answers from
this episode lucky for you I had
exclusive Midnight Club goodies from
Lilly Reinhardt and matron Amick let's
take a look Lily what was that like for
you to step into alice issue it was so
fun and different it's a really just
unique episode and the entire episode is
just a flashback with a little bit of
present-day
of Alice kind of setting the scene and
explaining to Betty telling her story as
a young teen serpent so yeah I got to
have a lot of fun with hair and makeup
and 90's wardrobe and some lip liner so
Mac spice yeah and psychotic I was sad
when that episode was over I liked
playing that character lives not that I
don't love playing Betty but it was just
it's so different from what I do every
day at work so now that episode was fun
because you got you know you really got
to see all of the parents as teenagers
and how different they all were and then
what happened that made them all change
hey there how Cooper
any chance here free for a malt at pops
do you think she regrets that this is
present day yes but she's got beautiful
babies out of it yeah you got me yeah
well I'm glad she's got her girls now
let's keep this momentum moving with
seven seconds in heaven all right guys
now everything kicked off with Alice
discovering that she's got a little
serpent bun in her oven and FP is the
father oh if only she knew that one day
an annoying imposter would pretend to be
her baby boy anyways while Alice was
pining after FP she let her feelings
wander during their first off board game
of g and g and she found herself in the
middle of a hot makeout sesh with Fred
Andrews you and Fred Andrews not to
worry phallus stands as the midnight
club continued and Hermione refused FPS
advances thank goodness FP and Alice and
Fred and Hermione paired off and
puckered up but I wonder where Fred was
when Hermione had a little drug filled
makeout with Reggie Mantle's dad during
ascension night I also wonder if this
on-screen smooch is what sparked cami
and Charles's real-life romance tell me
your thoughts in the comments below but
by the end of the episode Hermione was
secured in Hiram's arms and getting her
first gift from her future husband as
for the other couples well we discovered
that seer and Tom Keller were having a
secret romance ever since high school
and that Penelope blossom is actually
Clifford's sister it's disgusting yeah
apparently Penelope was an orphan being
raised in the sisters of quiet mercy and
the blossoms adopted this little
redheaded girl - at first be their
daughter and then groom her to be the
future wife of their son I can't make
this up this is what happened and it's
vile you married your brother Penelope
and you can't support your daughter for
having a super awesome girlfriend what's
up your ass Penelope
and with that irritating thought let's
channel our flashback frustrations into
hisses and kisses now my first hiss is
going to the fact that I now have more
questions than answers after watching
this episode and I'm annoyed that I
still have no idea how this Griffin's
and gargoyle game actually works kudos
on the whole ascension party thing I
thought you did all this also here's a
tiny nugget of a theory for you guys
remember when we saw Sierra drawing on
the bathroom wall with lipstick and then
the bathroom was covered in what looked
like red lipstick saying flip for your
fate during Sencha night do you think
there's a connection there or is this
all just really confusing I'm not quite
sure anyways
hisses - Jughead and the rest of our
Southside serpents for succumbing to the
game also kisses - finally seeing things
more the season and having all of our
serpents in the same room or should I
say bunker together hisses - the
midnight club spit packs that was just
gross
and for high schoolers doing drugs
fizzle rocks they're new just say no
river babes hisses - the blossoms for
adopting Penelope as a child bride for
their son what kind of family does that
that's not family it's basically incest
hisses - seen the young black hood aka
Hal Cooper lurking in the halls of
Riverdale high - the confusing mystery
behind Principal featherheads death that
was underwhelming and - the gargoyle
king and his little Twiggy arms hisses -
the random musical moment with the Fred
heads I just didn't need that in this
episode but kisses - the fact that we
now know how Cheryl inherited her epic
drug-infused dance moves
keeping it going with kisses kisses to
Alice for telling us this story so we
could have this epic episode and to
Riverdale for paying homage to The
Breakfast Club with Anthony Michael Hall
fYI is for all you young burger waves
out there your homework this weekend is
to watch The Breakfast Club before next
week and then comment below with your
thoughts kisses - seeing jug I mean F P
for rocking that crown - Fred for
running Nicky in the hallways with his
friend going straight
and to the look on Alice's face when she
was about to have a catfight with
Penelope and kisses to the perfect
casting of having Mark Consuelos as
real-life son Michael play young Hyrum I
was on the set of Riverdale with those
two fellas during this episode and got
the behind-the-scenes scoop
take a look did you have to audition I
did actually I'll tell you the whole
story because in season two I made a
cameo as a picture of my dad and so they
they called him and she asked my Pete
audition I'm a first-ever audition how
did you prepare for the role mark what
kind of advice did you give nothing I
told him just to memorize his lines he
already had him memorized and he went in
the next day for the producers you know
some of the crew here didn't know it was
him and they're like oh my god they
really did what that's it it's like wow
they did a great job he looks just like
him and that's how the Conan is not a
cauchy yeah I've got a nose you know
Riverdale has turned Cole and KJ and
quite the little heart throbs are you
prepared for the excitement and the
fandom that's coming your way go to
school he's gonna fish I can't say I'm
not looking for and there you have it
thank you so much for joining me in this
Sweetwater Secrets after-show and I'll
see you next time for our preview for
episode 305 chapter 40 The Great Escape
but for now hit subscribe so you never
miss all the Riverdale fun and give this
video a like and then head on down to
the comments and spill your deepest
darkest hisses and kisses which actor do
you think that the best job at
channeling their on-screen parent do you
agree with my theory that Sierra might
have something to do with the gng deaths
and which flashback revelation shook you
the most now I can't wait to read your
comments and I'll see you soon river
babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]